tras una serie de esquemas del Corán en
toda Europa nueve países occidentales
han anunciado el cierre temporal de sus
misiones diplomáticas en Turquía los
cierres se deben a motivos de seguridad
países como Estados Unidos y Alemania
afirman que los ataques contra sus
ciudadanos podrían ser más probables en
el país Los Embajadores de los nueve
países fueron convocados ankara y
criticados por su decisión al ministro
del interior Turco ha hablado de los
cierres
hay información que circula entre los
consulados y embajadas que hizo hincapié
en que easyl organizaría un ataque
terrorista contra consulares escuelas
religiosas extranjeras y lugares de
culto en Estambul las tensiones
aumentaron en enero cuando se quemó un
ejemplar del Corán ante la embajada
turca en Suecia el acto provocó la ira
de la población turca mayoritariamente
musulmana en Las dos últimas semanas
también se han quemado ejemplares de
libros a grandes Dinamarca y los Países
Bajos y el ministro Turco asuntos
exteriores dijo que se había detenido
una protesta similar en Noruega
Ya ven lo que pasó en Suecia y Dinamarca
mismo habría ocurrido en Noruega pero
convocamos al embajador noruego al
ministerio por la mañana desde entonces
han retirado el permiso no se trata de
libertad de expresión sino de un delito
de odio
la convocatoria de Embajadores en
Turquía no es más que el último aumento
de las tensiones diplomáticas el pasado
fin de semana Turquía emitió una alerta
de seguridad para sus propios ciudadanos
que viajan a Estados Unidos y a Europa
diciendo que podían sufrir ataques
islamófobos